[Music]  that's the manticore oh great and  powerful Manticore I understand there's  traffic you need to plan for that well  maybe your mother should get her own car  your fearlessness sir  my brother and I seek a map to a Phoenix  Jim oh well you've come to the right  turn I have the parchment you desire  right here Oh  the children's menu isn't that fun  they're all based on my old maps uh-oh  uh-oh the great magic or since you on  your adventure with a hero's blessing  and here's oh oh wait this is so fun Tom  it's fun you get a real different magic  when you put two people together here we  go I can't get this levitation spell the  work aloft Elavon you have to speak from  your hearts fire thank you from the  hearts fire what did you do at work  today Tom and I just shouted hots fire  and a lot fell apart  [Music]